[Music]
take it
this people
she is my friend my hero my favorite pop
star of all time and everyone else's and
the bestest our girl could ever have I'm
so excited
Q I'm so excited to present her with
this well-deserved recognition the
first-ever RDMA icon Britney Spears
Britney Spears younger sister Jamie Lynn
as surprises her by joining the tribute
performance as Britney received the icon
award at the 2017 Radio Disney Music
Awards what a pleasant surprise my
goodness I want to thank the bed Leah
performances celebrating Britt's vast
catalog were given by Kelsea Ballerini
Hailee Steinfeld and Sophia Carson
[Applause]
[Music]
you may be performed some iconic songs
for an icon in front of an icon really
happened did I really perform for
Britney Spears I before I stepped
onstage I was holding back tears I kept
thinking of Sofia when she was six years
old singing hit me baby one more time
and never in a million years what I've
ever dreamed I'd be singing it for
Britney
[Music]
you